when was the last time that you were
frustrated
or even angry
the potential for anger pervades modern
social life
whether it's
getting cut off in traffic maybe your
co-workers are giving you grief about
something
or maybe even in your family
people are frustrating you or they're
making you angry
now we all get angry
but now think back to that last time
that you experienced anger
and i want to ask
did you lash out at the other person
with physical aggression
now my guess is that you didn't do that
but why not
what came between you experiencing this
aggressive urge
and this outcome of not behaving
aggressively
what got in the middle
well i would argue that self-control is
one thing that got in the middle
now although we get angry on a
regular basis
we often live in a time
that's the most peaceful that we've ever
known in the history of the planet
stephen pinker in his book the better
angels of our nature talks about this
now when we understand why that is well
we can think of two components of
self-control that helps make that
possible
the first of which is monitoring now
remember monitoring keeping track of
your thoughts feelings and behaviors
that's a core feature of self-control
and the more that you're doing it the
better off you are
now how is our ability to monitor
aggression and violence
changed over the past couple hundred
years
well it's gotten a lot easier to do it
think of jay edgar hoover
now he was famous for a lot of different
reasons
but one thing that he did was he made it
a lot easier to monitor people in terms
of their criminal history
he was very much a proponent of having a
fingerprint registry to identify people
who had violent and criminal backgrounds
but j edgar hoover isn't where the
change stopped
if you look at the internet it's made it
a lot easier to keep track of people who
have committed crimes
you can even look up whether your
neighbor has a criminal history
so monitoring is one thing that's helped
us keep track of people who commit
violent crimes
but another thing that's changed that
can also help us explain why we live in
such a peaceful society
is that standards related to violence
and aggression have also changed
now remember a standard is simply a
reference point
a point on which most people can agree
that certain things are desirable or
appropriate and other things aren't
think of how this relates to aggression
how have attitudes and beliefs about the
appropriateness of aggression
changed over the past couple hundred
years
they've changed dramatically
when you're reading the newspaper
and you're looking at the obituaries
how often do you really see that someone
was killed in a duel
very very infrequently
yet the first treasury secretary of the
united states alexander hamilton that's
how he died
now we have a lot more effective ways of
resolving conflict and one reason for
that is that as culturals as cultures
progress
we develop standards in ways that we can
change our attitudes toward the
appropriateness of violence
because we don't have to use violence to
solve our conflicts we can use other
more effective ways another way of
understanding how standards have shifted
is simply looking at corporal punishment
and how that has become less and less
common in the united states public
school system
so currently 31 states in the united
states forbid the use of corporal
punishment in the public school setting
but what's most interesting is when did
that occur
there was a clear shift in the standard
as to when it became inappropriate to
use corporal punishment in public
schools
because of the 31 states that currently
forbid
corporal punishment in public schools
30 of them began to forbid corporal
punishment
after 1970.
so what we've seen are a couple
different reasons
why aggression has become less and less
common
and these reasons again relate to
self-control
by making it easier to monitor violence
and aggression we become a less violent
culture
and by shifting our standards
these things that we
use that guide and steer our behavior
by
talking about and thinking about
aggression as something that we should
not engage in to solve our problems
what we've seen are decreases in
aggression over time
so again what this shows us is the
importance of self-control in everyday
life
and how it can help us explain
why people even though they get angry on
a regular basis
oftentimes refuse to act on those
aggressive impulses
and instead use self-control
now although we live
in one of the most peaceful times in the
history of the world
aggression still occurs
and we have to ask ourselves why does
that happen
although
monitoring has become easier and
standards related to aggression have
changed
one thing that hasn't changed is our
strength
the amount of energy that it takes to
override an aggressive impulse
now a couple of criminologists sought to
understand what are some of the best
predictors of criminal behavior
and what they did was they combed over
hundreds of studies
to formulate what they called a general
theory of crime
now
all of their efforts paid off handsomely
and
at the end of the day they identified
two of what they called the best
predictors of criminal behavior the
first is simply opportunity when people
have more opportunities to engage in
criminal behavior they take advantage of
those opportunities
but the second factor is of particular
interest to us
self-control
and they looked at all sorts of signs
related to lapses in self-control as
helping to understand
why people engage in criminal behavior
now one of these examples comes from
burglaries
now we all have a stereotype in our head
of what burglaries kind of look like
we might see a
white van that's been stolen
there are burglars in the van and
they're all wearing black
and they might have ski masks on
and through a careful series of plans
they burglarize a house
or an institution
now the reality
is quite different
most burglaries are committed within a
mile of the perpetrator's home
so instead of
heisting
stolen goods using a stolen van
most people walk to the places that they
rob
so it's an act of impulsivity instead of
careful planning
violent crime is another example of
impulsivity at work
one way they can look at this is
think of factors that make people more
impulsive
that make people unable to control their
impulses and how that might play into
their propensity to engage in violent
behavior
think of
alcohol intoxication for example
now one report from the u.s department
of justice
argued that 40 percent of violent crimes
are committed when people are under the
influence when people are intoxicated
again what this shows is that when
people
are in a state where they can't control
their impulses very well such as when
they're intoxicated they're a lot more
likely to engage in violent behavior
another way to look at this is when
violent crimes are committed
so are most violent crimes committed
early in the day
when people are full of energy and can
regulate themselves or toward the end of
the day when people are fatigued and
worn out
well what the data suggests is that the
majority of violent crimes are committed
between 10 pm
and 2 am
again this is a time when people are
often fatigued when they're unable to
control their impulses again showing us
a link although it's a correlation
but a reliable link
between
lapses and self-control and violent
crime
but what happens
when you put these two things together
let's think of bars
and bars are places where people have
lots of fun but they're often times
where people get alcohol to drink where
people become intoxicated
and we know that when people are
intoxicated they're a lot more likely to
engage in violent behavior
but we can correlate that as well
with how long the bars actually stay
open
and one recent study has shown
that the longer that bars stay open
the more violent crimes are committed
now although this is simply a
correlation an association between two
different variables
what it suggests
is that not only by becoming intoxicated
are you more likely to engage in violent
crime
but by being intoxicated at a time of
day when you're mentally fatigued
it can prove extremely costly
now the researchers in charge of this
wanted to quantify the financial costs
associated with this spike in violent
crime when bars stay open late at night
and what they showed was that bars in
new york that stayed open after 1am
it was associated with an increase of
costs associated with violence
of
194 million dollars
now that's not a trivial cost
and it also doesn't take into account
all of the other negative consequences
that accompany violence
when people feel frustrated or angry
do they need self-control energy in
order to override their urge to behave
aggressively
can this help us explain
why some people
have problems controlling their
aggressive impulses
and why some people even succumb to
those impulses
and engage in actual aggressive behavior
to explore this possibility a group of
researchers conducted a simple
experiment
what they did was they invited some
college students into a laboratory and
they had them sit down at a table
and they told them that this experiment
investigated taste testing
the first thing that they were going to
do was compose an essay that was
about a topic that was important to them
the experimenter collected the essay
left
came back and this time the experimenter
had
a plate of food
that the experimenter sat in front of
the participant
now for half of the participants they
sat in front of a food that was
extremely
delicious
it was a donut
the experimenter said what i'd like for
you to do is eat the donut and tell us
what you think about it
how sweet it is and other sorts of
things that'll tell us what this donut
tastes like
next
the experimenter waited for the
participant to begin to eat the donut
and as soon as the participant lifted
the donut up to take a bite the
experimenter said wait do not eat the
doughnut i made a mistake i'm sorry put
the donut down
i'm going to leave and i'm going to fix
this so that we can go and get on with
the rest of this study but whatever you
do don't eat the donut
now the idea
is that by sitting in front of this
donut that you're not supposed to eat it
takes a lot of self-control not to eat
it
now it was so difficult in fact that for
a couple of these participants
they ate it anyway
now the other half of the participants
they sat in front of a piece of food
that was less tempting they sat in front
of a radish
so the idea is that for some of these
participants they had to exert a lot of
self-control not to eat this food that
was in front of them
whereas other participants
had to exert very little self-control
not to eat the food that was in front of
them
next what the experimenter did was the
experimenter came back
and gave them some feedback about their
essay
that was ostensibly from another person
now in reality
this other person worked for the
experimenter it was a confederate
and the feedback was extremely negative
the reason the feedback was negative is
the experimenters wanted to evoke a
sense of frustration in participants and
it was effective
but the next thing that the
experimenters did was they gave
participants an opportunity to lash out
at this person who had just frustrated
them
how did they do this
well in this study what they did was
they gave participants a plate full of
chips
and a bottle of hot sauce
and they told them that they could dump
as much of this hot sauce on the chips
as they wanted to
and this plate of food was going to go
to the person who just frustrated them
but the key is that this partner that
they had who had just insulted them
hated spicy foods
so the more hot sauce that participants
put onto these chips the more
aggressively they were behaving
what they found is that participants who
had been depleted of their mental energy
who had exerted a lot of mental effort
to not eat that tempting donut they
behaved a lot more aggressively when
they were provoked
now a follow-up study
replicated those results
of when people are depleted of their
self-control energy that they're more
likely to lash out at others
but what this follow-up study also did
was it took into account people's levels
of self-control that they brought with
them into the laboratory
their general dispositions and abilities
to control their impulses
and what the researchers found
is that by understanding the traits that
people bring with them to situations
people's general ability to control
their impulses
it helped them predict who is most
likely to behave aggressively
so it wasn't just being depleted of
mental energy that increased aggression
but it was also
when people
are depleted of their mental energy
and they have a low ability to control
their impulses
those are the people who are most likely
to lash out at others
so what these findings again show us is
the complexity of self-control
and how it unders and how it helps us
understand
who is most likely to behave
aggressively and under what
circumstances
it's important to understand
that self-control is limited and when
people
have limited energy to control their
impulses
they're often going to behave more
aggressively
but this relationship is especially
pronounced among people who naturally
have an inability to control their
impulses
so by understanding
how these two factors interact with each
other
we can better understand why aggression
occurs
and who is most at risk for behaving
aggressively
we've been talking about how
self-control can help us explain
criminal behavior
and aggression between strangers
but can self-control help us understand
aggression between people who love each
other romantic partners
intimate partner violence
now intimate partner violence occurs at
alarmingly high rates
among college students there are
estimates that as many as 34 percent of
college students report at least one act
of physical aggression in their
relationship over the past year
now if we go outside of the college
population among
adults in the united states who are in
long-term romantic relationships the
rates aren't as high
but they're still about 20 percent
so can self-control help us
understand who is most at risk for
behaving aggressively
well researchers have begun to explore
this question
and one way that they've been doing this
is with controlled laboratory
experiments
now in one laboratory experiment they
brought couples into the research lab
and they had them do
tasks that either depleted them of their
self-control energy or did not deplete
them
specifically they had participants watch
a video program where they either had to
control their attention or they didn't
have to control their attention
next participants were provided with
some feedback from their romantic
partner
now in reality the feedback was prepared
ahead of time by the experimenters
the feedback was either extremely
positive
or extremely negative
and the idea was that the experimenters
wanted to make participants happy with
their partner
or kind of frustrated with their partner
next
the experimenters gave participants an
opportunity
to make their partner engage in some
physically painful activities
specifically
they gave them a list of yoga positions
that they could decide for their partner
to do
and how long they had to hold each one
now the experimenter told participants
that
these yoga positions they won't cause
any permanent physical damage
but they're extremely painful
so the prediction is that when
participants were depleted of their
self-control energy and they had been
frustrated by their romantic partner
that they would make their partner hold
the yoga positions longer than anyone
else in the study
and that's exactly what the researchers
found
when people were depleted of their
self-control energy
and their partner had frustrated them
they made their partner hold those yoga
positions a lot longer than anyone else
in the in the actual experiment
but what this study left out was an
important factor
so we know that depleted self-control
energy
mixed with frustration will increase
aggressiveness even in romantic
relationships
but what we don't know
is whether this effect is most
pronounced among people who are
naturally aggressive people
so to explore this possibility
a group of researchers brought in a
couple of samples of dating participants
and what they had them do was complete a
measure of self-control
and at the end of the day they reported
on how much their partner had provoked
them
they also completed a measure that
assessed how naturally physically
aggressive they were
another thing that the experimenters did
at the end of the day
was they showed participants a doll
that represented their partner
and what they told participants
is that this doll represents your
partner and because we've been asking
you lots of questions about your partner
and maybe some negative behaviors
we want to give you an opportunity to
let some of that negative energy out
and so what you can do is you can insert
some pins
into this doll that represents your
partner
from 0
to 51 pins and this was used as a
measure of aggressive inclinations
so as predicted
when people had low levels of
self-control
and they were highly provoked by their
partner
they put the most pins into the doll
but this was most pronounced among
people who were naturally aggressive
these three factors created a perfect
storm
in helping us to identify who is most at
risk for behaving aggressively
and this study was replicated among a
sample of newlywed couples
and instead of using the doll measure of
aggressive inclinations they found the
same results with actual physical
aggression in the relationship
so what these results tell us is that
self-control can help us explain not
only criminal behavior and aggression
between strangers it can help us explain
who is most at risk for behaving
aggressively
in their romantic relationships and why
what can neuroscience tell us about the
relationship between self-control and
aggression
well there are a couple different ways
of getting at this question
one way that we can do this
is we can identify people
who are at highest risk for behaving
aggressively and we can look at how
their brains function
researchers have begun to do this
and they've identified the most violent
people on the planet
people who are psychopaths
and what they've done is they've
explored how the psychopathic brain
might differ from people who are not
psychopathic
what they've shown consistently
are some differences
and these differences are related to
self-control
one reliable difference in the
psychopathic brain
is that they have less volume
in the frontal lobe the prefrontal
cortex and this is the seat of
self-control
now although they have reduced volume in
the prefrontal cortex
psychopaths have more volume
in the reward center of the brain
also known as the striatum
so you can think of the psychopathic
brain as a brain
that functions a little bit differently
than the rest of our
brains there's less activation going on
in the prefrontal cortex
which is the brain region that helps us
override impulses
and when we think of what those impulses
feel like the psychopathic brain
they experience stronger reward
responses
so this is one way that you can
understand the relationship between
self-control and aggression using
neuroscience
another way is to look at how healthy
normal folks
respond in aggressive situations
using functional magnetic resonance
imaging
and so one study did this very thing
they brought a group of participants
into a laboratory and sat them down in
an fmri scanner
next what they did was they frustrated
participants while they were having
their brains scanned
the way that they did this
is the person who was talking to them
through the microphone intercom system
started insulting them a little bit
making them angry
what they found
is that when people were insulted
blood began to flow to a region of the
brain called the anterior cingulate
cortex
this is a region of the brain that tells
you that something is going completely
wrong in your environment and you have
to do something to correct it
next what participants were given was an
opportunity to ruminate
what they showed was that when people
were ruminating they were using a region
of the brain that's involved in active
regulation the prefrontal cortex
so now we can begin to see
why people lash out at others after
they've engaged in rumination
rumination wears people out because
blood is flowing to the prefrontal
cortex
so i think we've begun to see how
neuroscience can help us explain who is
most at risk for behaving aggressively
and why
we've learned that there's a clear
relationship between self-control and
aggression
people who have poor self-control are
often extremely aggressive people
and factors that might undermine our
ability to control our impulses can
increase our chances of lashing out at
others
what are some activities that we can use
to reduce our aggressive inclinations
one thing that we can do
is to build our self-control strength
now because self-control relies on a
common energy resource
when we practice self-control in one
domain
it helps us in other even unrelated
domains
so for this activity what i would like
for you to do
is for one week between 8 am
and 6 pm
use your non-dominant hand for everyday
activities
whether it's cooking your food
brushing your teeth
or using your telephone
it's going to take self-control to
complete this activity
it might even be frustrating or
exhausting early on that's why you're
going to do it over an extended period
of time
by practicing self-control what you're
going to find is that when you're
confronted with situations where you
become angry and frustrated you're going
to have added self-control muscle to
overcome your
impulses and scientific studies has
shown that this activity
actually reduces people's aggressive
inclinations when they're mentally
fatigued
a second activity is far simpler
we know that having adequate metabolic
energy
is helpful in helping people have good
self-control
we also know that people who struggle
with metabolic energy who feel like they
have low blood sugar
they're often more likely to lash out at
other people
and so what i'd like for you to do is to
strategically keep food around
but not any food
what i want you to do is target foods
that are going to give you a boost of
metabolic energy
now although this might be straight up
sugar
what i would argue is that a much more
effective use of your energy can be
gotten through proteins
things that are going to break down into
energy a lot slower
and by doing this
you're going to be a lot less likely to
lash out at other people
these two activities will help you gain
skills and strength
so that you might not engage in
behaviors that you might regret later
[Music]
you